how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything relating to the mcu and
of course recently the
spider-verse it seems like all of the
talk recently has been about spider-man
3.
and rightfully so with all the rumors
and reports that we've gotten for the
film plus the production has started and
tom holland and zendaya are officially
in atlanta
on set and now of course everybody is
waiting to see if the spider-verse is
something that is really going to come
to fruition in the marvel cinematic
universe
and based off of everything that we've
heard it definitely looks like it is and
today we have another
exciting piece to the puzzle and this
time concerning our man
miles morales there have been recent
reports that he is going to be
in spider-man 3 and we even have some
sort of a leaked audition tape for a
character that definitely fits the bill
for miles
perfectly then at the same time we do
have reports that state marvel has
already cast the actor they want to play
for miles morales although it's not sure
or not if he's going to appear in
spider-man 3 or a future film but don't
worry i have some clarity for you in
this video but first if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest
mcu and spider-man news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a spider-man
imposter funko pop so some of you may
recall that on july 4th
of this year i actually did a video
about miles morales coming to the mcu
now this was before all of the hype and
knowledge that spider-man 3 would be a
spider-verse movie
however i received a report from
gegositymag.com owner mikey sutton
stating that he heard miles was making
his way to the mcu
and now several months later it looks
like that is finally happening
and now we have a little bit more
information on what exactly could come
of miles morales entering the mcu and
the spider-verse
mikey says that right now as rumor has
it the
live-action spider-verse will end up
becoming the miles morales franchise
and the reason for this is that this
will accomplish two major goals
first it will finally provide miles
morales with a series of movies beyond
his animated
into the spider-verse films miles
morales has been a fan favorite even
before
into the spider-verse but there's no
doubt that into the spider-verse just
blew him up
everybody seems to love him and he needs
to join tom holland spider-man on the
silver screen while keeping peter parker
as well
so of course we can get the best of both
worlds because we do love tom hall and
spider-man as well
and a second point calling them
spider-verse films will lessen
any confusion with the tom holland
spider-man movies
and they'll be branded with a familiar
title as well and this is a problem that
we've had
a little bit of confusion on in the past
and it's already been confirmed that
this is in fact a concern
for marvel studios some of you may
recall that for the first
venom movie sony wanted tom holland to
make a cameo
however marvel studios said no they
didn't want people to confuse the two
universes
they didn't want people thinking that
venom existed within the marvel
cinematic universe with iron man captain
america
thor etc however that was before the big
tom holland sony disney scare and after
that we know that they renegotiated
their deal to use spider-man and the
morbius trailer and all the reports that
we have for spider-man 3 pretty much
confirm the fact that the two universes
are indeed going to be colliding in some
way shape or form and kevin feige the
president of marvel studios has already
said that spider-man is one of the only
characters that has the ability to jump
into different universes so i think it's
all but confirmed that the spider-verse
and the sharing between the mcu
and the spumc for sony is going to
happen
and there needs to be a way to make it a
little less confusing
so branding some movies spider-verse
films would be a pretty decent way to
distinguish hey
these movies exist not just within one
universe but actually a couple of them
but now the question is if we get a
miles morales franchise who is going to
lead that franchise will it be kevin
feige at marvel studios or will it be
sony well mikey has heard that the plan
is disney and sony would like a few mcu
superheroes to meet the new kid on the
block
they would like miles to meet and be
recruited by the young avengers
discussions are for him to join the
young avengers and be the spider-man in
their theatrical film
when they make the leap from disney plus
to the cinemas now this is a very
interesting idea and one that i
personally very like because i do think
tom holland should definitely be with
the main avengers and should even go on
to become one of the leaders of the main
avengers but i still would love to see a
spider-man on the young avengers and
miles is
younger and peter could be his mentor
and with tom holland spider-man leading
the avengers he would definitely be a
mentor to all of the young avengers as
well
so going forward this would be a great
setup for peter parker and
miles morales two spider-man existing in
the same universe and
kind of others as well fighting on their
own sometimes coming together to fight
and
fighting with their avengers groups so
we have a ton of reports stating that
miles is on his way to the marvel
cinematic universe and
spider-verse and it looks like marvel
has some pretty decent plans for him
if everything comes true and if i hear
any more i'll be sure to update you with
everything i hear so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news
and let me know your thoughts about
miles morales joining the young avengers
in the comments down below do you like
this
do you not like it let me know don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof